i want to congratulate you recently
celebrated your first
father's day yes i did i did how are you
balancing
work and life as a dad and also do you
ever get the
feeling of like i just gotta get home to
baby like you wanna work
as fast as you can 100 i just got back
uh two days ago from london
filming persuasion uh with netflix and i
was there for
in total about two and a half months
baby came out for like the first
three and a half four weeks but then the
rest of that period i was kind of away
even for my first
father's day i was like had to do it
over the phone
so by the end of it i was just like
yearning to be home and
she was actually here last night and
been trying to spend as much time as
possible together
you get to do the best you can you have
to it's a treasure it's a challenging
career path and to bring your family
along because it's so unorthodox right
your hours are so crazy
you have to be away that's right that's
part of the game the three challenges of
the warrior
[Music]
the three challenges in the what now do
you feel like you're an action star
because you know what i said when i
walked out of theater yesterday i said
move over jason stay them and the rock
there we go
henry's here and that's how i really
feel i mean i got the goosebumps
thank you so much taking on a role like
that the physicality that's needed
isn't something that i've kind of
stretched and exercised before in in
previous movies when they sort of asked
me about you know what are your thoughts
on coming with us and making this movie
there was this sort of like right i've
been waiting for something to
to really sort of throw myself at
physically
um and quite the movie to to sort of
jump in at the deep end with because
it's not just an action film it's a real
martial arts film so like all the action
that you saw it's
not too much sort of shooting at things
which was a little bit easier but
physically it's demanding like it was it
really tore up my body for a while
uh majority of it was uh the katana work
and the choreography and the
the sort of slipping from from combatant
to combatant and making it look
seamless so it was a tremendous amount
of cardio
that really low kind of horse stance
uh and that first week of of sort of
training i remember i was just like
wow i can barely sit down or like get up
from a chair
just because you're so low in this
stance for like the longest time
join us this
is your destiny
talk to me about how excited you're
going to be to show this film
to your daughter when she gets old
enough what do you hope
when she sees it she thinks about her
dad in this moment in time because for
me like i'm a fan of you
but now you've jumped into the genre
that i love like i'm a fan of this genre
and i think you've done it
seamlessly and especially with a film
like this and a character like snake
eyes
there's a real kind of misnomer of
trying to make them too
masculine and to sort of prov like too
much bravado but with
with our snake eyes he's he's full of
flaws he's he's a guy who's made massive
mistakes in his past life
um but i think those attributes really
endear um him to the audience members at
large
because he's like you and i you know we
we mess up
but if you're diligent you're
hard-working you choose the right path
you can become something great so for me
hopefully when my baby sort of
grows up she won't be sick of me going
hey you should watch this movie because
you know this was a time when i was
amazing and i could do all this stuff
now i'm kind of
old and decrepit or whatever it's
interesting you say that because you you
sort of
you take into account what kind of
movies she'll
she's going to be watching in the future
so i have this amazing animated film
with uh
paramount that we're doing right now
called the tigers apprentice and that
was something that
i was like oh it'd be amazing to show
her and she'd love to be sort of like
taken away in that animated world can
you share anything about that or is it
too soon i mean it's based on
uh a beautiful book by uh lawrence yap
um and uh i play uh the tiger
um the tigers apprentice we have a
fantastic
well-rounded asian cast because it sort
of lives in that world
um but i can't give too much away just
yet i want to ask
one thing for the other fan base crazy
rich asians whose
yard do i have to mow a car do i have to
watch to get a sequel is there any talk
you know i've been saying this to pretty
much everybody is like i think i'm going
to find out
uh of snake eyes too far faster than i
will of
uh crazy rotations too so we'll take it
we'll take it either way
we'll do let's do it we'll slaughter it
in between the uh
the ninja fighting and stuff we'll go
back to singapore and film it real quick
you know you touched a little bit
earlier on finishing up persuasion with
dakota johnson
what can fans expect from this version
dj
like steals the show for sure her
version of anne is
absolutely sublime amazing co-actor
cosmo jarvis
who's uh phenomenal and calm with horses
which which was one of his latest films
but
uh the the movie itself is a very
sort of um it's very true to the
original
uh sort of text from uh from jane austen
um but with slight sort of modern twists
in in humor um and kind of little subtle
nods of like yeah you know we're making
this with
a sort of a cheeky wink so it's exciting
in that sense so i think
a lot of people are going to be drawn to
it especially the younger
jane austen fans who kind of love like
slightly modern adaptations but still
in that world you mentioned dj steals
the show is she fun to work with
she's awesome i imagine you guys
together you know she keeps the
the positivity the angie on set like she
literally
hadn't stopped filming that entire
period of time i sort of jumped in and
fluttered around and came and
got dressed up and smiled but she was
literally every single day
working her ass off
i've been following you for some time do
i know you
yeah i know you snake guys
was there anything that you liberated
from seth like you're playing with i
like that oh yeah
that's a gentle way to put it right
politically correct someone like you're
playing
essentially every fella's dream role on
your
gi joe origins man there were so many
really cool things and there's a
tremendous amount of easter eggs
in the movie itself with nods to the old
films
nods to sort of a comic book sort of era
for me
you know morning light is one of the
most iconic sort of swords
um out there but sadly there was
literally one hero sword
which took some poor sod weeks and
of hours to be able to sort of make so i
couldn't literally lift that because
they were like well you might need it
for like the next sort of movies or
whatever
um but uh i i m perhaps misplaced a
jacket or two
lost on set somewhere never to be found